these CBS regret getting plastic surgery
and here's why so Kylie Jenner secret
got a boob job at 19 years old and 6
months later after she got pregnant for
the first time she wished never got them
done she said before the surgery they
were beautiful and the perfect size and
she recommends that anyone who wants to
have it done wait until after they have
kids Denise Richards also got breast
implants at 19 and she said the doctor
gave her implants that were bigger than
what she asked for and that when she
went to a second doctor to get them
corrected he gave her even bigger ones
and she didn't sue because she was
getting ready to film a movie and she
didn't want to be in a lawsuit with a
plastic surgeon Reed eing from Modern
Family got cheek implants at 19 he was
so uncomfortable with the results that
he hid in his apartment for 6 months
after he actually got addicted to
plastic surgery and he got seven more
cosmetic surgeries done before he vowed
to stop when he was 24 years old B Hadid
has also said that she regrets getting a
nose job at 14 years old she said that
she wishes she kept the nose of her
ancestors and that she thinks she would
have grown into it and Tor spelling Got
Her Boobs done when she was in her early
20s and she said that if she had known
that it could possibly impact the
production of milk she never would have
done it